Democratic congressman Joe Kennedy the
third is criticizing the idea of arming
teachers to protect schools we spoke
with a massachusetts lawmaker for CBS
Sunday morning he says the government is
not taking enough action to make sure
that kids are safe and to prevent school
shootings here's a look at part of our
conversation it is frustrating it is
empowering it is humbling it's enraging
to see high school students have to bear
this responsibility on their shoulders
because their government won't because
adults that are supposed to protect them
refuse to to see that we can't have a
reasonable conversation about ways to to
make sure that a parent can send their
kid off to school and not have to worry
whether they're going to come home and
to have to have these absurd
conversations about arming teachers and
turning our schools and the fortresses
no I don't feel that's absurd I think
it's absurd I think it's absurd on so
many levels and you can watch our full
story with Congressman Kennedy on CBS
Sunday morning he talks about his family
he's got a great smart wife two gorgeous
kids and his thoughts about running for
president you can watch it Sunday right
here on CBS and we talked about that
chapstick go to I was gonna ask you yes
he's got a very good sense of humor and
people are sending him chapstick to the
office every single day a new load comes
in that was he gave the response on this
day of the Union after President Trump
and people thought his lips looked a
little looked like he was drooling a
little bit he was not that was just very
shiny chapstick really interested
interview on Sunday more guys good guy